hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse
I'm so sorry about starting this late I
can see you've all been busy in the live
chat so hopefully there was some good
conversation going on I have not had a
chance to read any of this so I'm
scrolling through it now all right so I
was as supposed to have a very brief
conversation and it turned into a almost
two-hour meeting so that's why I started
late I thought I would have plenty of
time to get started or to get ready for
the stream and stream but it didn't
happen like that so I guess as a as
asking how the meetings were actually
the meetings they there are basically
about all the projects that we're going
to be doing for the next year I
shouldn't say all of them I'm sure some
other things will come up but I have a
much better idea about what I'll be
working on and how that that main
website so mentioned a few days ago the
main University website franciscan CD
you will be completely redoing that
front end and back end I have a much
better a clearer picture of what's
wanted for that and what's what the
design is going to be like so I'll be
sharing that with you in future streams
but I know I have we sketched out some
things on a whiteboard and I took a
picture of it so I wouldn't forget so
I'll be will be working on it but it was
a long
but it did we sorted quite a few things
out one thing that we are going to be
working on within the next two weeks or
so and we'll see maybe I'll do it on a
stream maybe I won't it depends on if
you are interested we're going to try to
take so the main website right now has
an event system that's really hard to to
work with in terms of adding the content
for the events so we're going to take I
may as well give you something to look
at what we're talking about this to you
all right so what we're gonna do not in
this stream but in the next week or so
we're gonna redo the events so that
we'll use some third-party systems so
here's here's right now how the events
show up and there are other places
throughout the website that these events
show up for now I think we'll just worry
about this spot but we're going to
remove all of this and replace it and
instead we're going to pool events from
some other systems so it may be a Google
Calendar it might be Eventbrite it may
be a custom post type from WordPress
installation however so someone else in
my department is in charge of entering
in the data for these events whatever
they decide is going to be the best
system for them that's going to you save
them as much time as possible
we're going to work with that system so
I don't know what it'll be right up you
know right away but it's going to be
something that definitely it has to have
an API so we're going to replace all of
this with whatever that system is that's
going to hopefully free up some time for
this other person and they're gonna
learn react they're actually going to do
a clone of our project one the the cata
catechol Institute website they're going
to do a clone of that and they're going
to use that for another University
website and in the process hopefully
they're going to learn react so if
somebody else in
department that can can do react sites
so that's right so my job in the next
week or two is to free up their time by
making this event system a lot easier to
work with
so that's coming if you're interested in
that then let me know I'll try to stream
when we do that so let me know we'll see
I'm still undecided as to whether it's
it'll be worth it to stream okay so
today I don't know what did I say we're
gonna do today
Passport yeah passport j/s okay I'm just
briefly checking the live chat see if
there's anything I should address right
away before we get started okay I'll
probably be probably missing a lot of
things since I'm skimming through so
quickly but it looks okay it doesn't
look like there's is anything here okay
so here's what I'm going to do I'm gonna
start my 25-minute Pomodoro timer if
you've asked the question I will get to
it after we do our first coding session
of 25 minutes so I'll take a five-minute
break and then I'll start going through
questions no matter what at the end of
the stream I'll go through all the
questions so please don't feel like
you're being ignored if I haven't
answered your question yet I'm just
gonna break it up a little bit and get
to the questions a little bit later so
hang in there and I will try to answer
your question at first here's what I
think we're going to do
Harshit has added a pull request that
did a lot of work to the server so
before we try to implement anything with
passport j/s on the server we're better
off merging that in I think that'll be
much easier to handle to do it that way
instead of trying to handle
all the merge conflicts that will happen
so I've already pulled down I'm gonna
double-check and make sure that
nothing's been added to his pull request
but otherwise earlier I've already
pulled it down as a separate branch so
it shouldn't be that hard to just merge
it in right from the command line so on
my other screen I have this pull request
open I'm just verifying that the last
commit let's see the last commit was
okay so there has not it looks like
there has not been another commit since
the last time I pulled everything down
so that's great okay so let me bring
this over then see all can see it so I
was about to do it anyway okay so
briefly give this a look and
let's see so you can see we have some
extra things here we're doing you know
webbing emailed ojs file that's handling
sending the emails from our form also
attachments the app touch as file in the
end the server has a lot of extra stuff
in there too using a motor to handle
form data we have fetch working in here
so we have some stuff set up I can't
remember how much of this was from a
previous pull request and how much was
this this last one so maybe going over
some stuff that we've already seen but I
had a little bit of trouble getting
things to work I don't think it had
anything to do with with any of the code
I think it had something to do with me
setting up an account to handle the mail
so I'm gonna go ahead and pull this in
but if if you happen to clone this
repository and it doesn't work for you
when you try to submit the form I'm
aware that something's wrong with the
way I'm doing it so as soon as I figure
that out then I'll let you know
I wasn't harsh it had given me some
suggestions for how to troubleshoot that
but I've been in meetings for three
hours straight so I have not been able
to even attempt to to troubleshoot so
tell you I had an issue but I just
really didn't have time to try to fix it
so I'm not that worried about it let's
see all right let's merge this in so
just I'm just going to double check and
make sure I don't have anything in
master that should have been merged okay
great we're up to date I'm gonna go back
to the master branch and I'm gonna run a
git merge and I'm gonna merge in this
branch which contains all the work that
Harsha did and merge it into master
there we go I'm just I think I already
brought everything in in terms of the
packages but I'm gonna run your own
again just to be sure yep
we're good so make sure that you do that
if you bring in this this latest code
locally to your machine be sure to run
an NPM install or yarn because there's
quite a few packages that that have been
added okay great so now that we have
that in there we can get to work on
actually let me push that up there we go
just want to make sure make sure that I
push that so in case you all want to get
the latest the latest code pulled down
on your machines you have it now and see
let me bring over let's see I'm John I
have a lot of stuff open a lot of
windows on my other screen so I'm just a
little little clutter and I didn't have
a chance to unclutter things before the
stream okay here it is alright so let me
bring this over this is the github repo
for passport j/s which is what we're
going to be using so you can check that
out if you like um actually I'll paste
in the live chat the link and that way
you can you can go right there if you
want to look at it and also here's the
link to the main site and to the docs so
we'll be going off looking at these docs
I know this is really small I'll zoom in
a bit but this is the passport Jay s dot
work site so here's what we need to do
though the way at least from what I've
read so far the way passport UAS works
is that there are a lot of these extra
modules that you can use depending on
what kind of authentication you want so
we need to we need to come to a decision
about what do we want what we want to do
with authentication and I'm not I have
an idea what I want to do but I'm not a
hundred percent sure so I'm gonna run
some things by you all and and see what
what you think and if anyone has any
input so currently
let's see currently we at the university
use for all the accounts I believe it's
it's Active Directory and right now the
single sign-on system that all the other
university stuff is tied into but not
the bulletin that we're working on I
think is using I'm gonna say sam'l it's
saml I'm not really sure how people say
that normally I've only ever read it but
I don't currently have all the
information I need to implement that
system I think the best case scenario
would be to get on that same system and
then all user accounts will be handled
by the IT department which which would
be really nice so it would all be one
system and I I think that would be
what's best for the users and then that
would be what's best for me as well and
not having to continually perform you
know maintenance tasks to make sure
everybody can log in and handle support
calls about login issues which is fine
but that's not really what my position
is supposed to do I'd much rather spend
time building new things so I'm not sure
how on board IT is with sharing the
information I need to bring that into
the system
I'll need to do some more work in terms
of talking to people before I can get to
that point so I'm wondering if I should
just go ahead and implement all the code
and assume that I'm going to get the
information that I need it sometime in
the next few days I mean meaning like
next week or should we try to use some
other type of basic system assuming that
maybe we
be able to tie in the university system
and so we'll have to do something else
on our own I'm not sure so basically the
choices as I see it is start building it
out to use sam'l hoping that we get the
other information we need from the IT
department to finish that at some point
next week or do we just pick a different
system for users to be able to log in
and implement that and then if we
eventually get information for an IT we
can switch over to something else but
for now we we could do something
different so if anybody has any opinions
on that let me know I'm gonna give it
maybe like 30 seconds a minute just to
get some feedback otherwise I'm just
gonna have to flip a coin or something
I'm have to figure it out I guess if you
need some more info on what I need to do
is basically what I need is only people
who work for the university should be
able to login I don't have access to a
list of all the people that work for the
University the best I have is that
somebody who has a university email and
if I could verify that they actually
have access to that email by sending an
email link that's the only way that I
can do this at this point so whatever I
do I need it so that the bulletin is
only accessible by people with a
Franciscan ddu email address so
something like a password this login
with an email link is what we're using
right now through a different system I
want to switch
I haven't the system I'm using currently
hasn't been a hundred percent reliable
so I don't want to do it the exact same
way but if we could figure out some way
to you an email link password this login
that'll work for now and then I guess
we get hope that we we can tie it in in
a better way later on let's see all
right I'm gonna check out the live chat
now and see what you all you all think
okay okay so we do have password let's
log in some of your saying we should do
password this at least Sebastian says if
it were me I wouldn't even try to do any
type of login until you are sure of what
you need and what you can use yeah I
mean that's not really a bad idea I just
I feel like we're getting to the point
where I need to start doing something
with this because in terms of the
project itself we have all the main
pieces there we just have a couple more
UI things to work out but I think we're
getting close to this being you know
usable I mean it's certainly you it's
currently is usable it's not perfect but
it fulfills all the requirements that we
need right now at this point and the
last requirement left is to make sure
that its users have to be authenticated
to access this this site so that's why I
just want to kind of move on with it one
way or another
okay
okay was umberto says that's how I
implemented our HR web portal in
register screen active directory pool
email address there were no user entry
allowed interesting
okay cool harsh it actually has a link
to a passport password list great you
know what I thought there was a password
list module I was looking for it
yesterday but I couldn't find it in
their list of modules on their on their
website there's like 300 models on their
website though and I was just scanning
through so I I probably just missed it
let's see
but I was pretty sure that I had seen
the password list login system used with
passport before in a tutorial that I saw
probably months ago let's see okay so I
see this NPM passport password list do
they have a github usually there's a
link to the github right there but I
don't see it
here we go
all right so I found it great so found
the github repo for this let me pull
this over let's check this out and see
see if this will work actually I see a
lot activity in the live chat too so
let's see
okay
all right let me see I'm Bertos
explaining how he set this up so let me
go through some of this stuff as well
they're just there's just been a lot in
the last chat with in the last 30
seconds or so
okay so embarrassin saying send a
verification email and then add user to
identity server or the identity store
then the next time they access the
system if they are registered it uses a
D violin doz login to authenticate and
authorize cool I mean that's that's what
I really want to do I just don't have I
don't really have information or access
to what we're currently doing with with
a D with Active Directory
okay so it looks like Harshit saying
there are two different ones here so
there's a just password list and then
there's a password password this he's
recommending to use the one that's just
password lists okay as we could check
that one out as well hmm
hmm
okay so I'm looking at this password
this as well okay interesting
here's now here's another thing to keep
in mind I don't know the answer this I'm
just I'm asking so right now we're
comparing these two different modules
one is works with Passport
the other one it looks like just works
on its own it's it's not tied in with
Passport what I hope will happen is at
some point we'll switch away from this
and will actually be tied in more
closely with the single sign-on system
that the university is using if that's
the case would it be better now even
let's let's assume for a second that
this password list is better than
passport password this even if that is
the case would it be better to just
implement this passport password list
knowing that we're going to switch to
some other passport solution maybe
password passport sam'l or something
like that I don't know I'm wondering
what what opinion you all have on that
hmm
I actually already have an email Jas
account set up so it wouldn't be that
hard to put that in
hmm
okay let's check this one out briefly
and let's see
okay so it looks like a few you're
saying in the live chat here that if I
do plan on switching to use sam'l with
Passport
then maybe I should set it up just to
use Passport right now okay that's kind
of what I was thinking I wanted I just
looked through the passport password
lists I just want to take a brief glance
at this password list repository just to
see if anything stands out that could be
a deal-breaker okay
hmm
okay
interesting I I didn't really see
anything in either one that makes me
really want to choose one or the other I
mean I just looking at the documentation
this one seems a bit more simple it
could be that just it doesn't explain as
much in the documentation though - so
all right let's see all right okay harsh
it says we should check out password
list dotnet
hmm
okay just to keep in mind as well I'm
gonna throw this up here this is what I
was thinking of using passport saml so
if anybody's interested in checking that
out I'm hoping at some point that we
implement this or something like it so I
came through the link in as well into
the live chat
Harshit says you can also send SMS with
it it the SMS thing is cool but I can't
I can't use the SMS right now because
the it has to be the email so I wouldn't
I wouldn't be able to use it because the
email is the only way I can really make
sure that it's somebody that works at
the University because they have an
active University email account
okay let me take a break now and answer
some questions we didn't didn't actually
get any code worked out but as soon as
we as soon as I make a decision we will
get some code let's see
okay
all right Blake Blake says could you
link their email to their phone number
actually that's interesting that might
be possible hmm I'll consider that let's
see all right I'm gonna scroll up and
try to go through and answer some
questions it looks like yeah I don't I
don't have everything that was in the
live chat so it cut off so if you ask
something closer to the very beginning
of when the stream was supposed to start
I can't see it anymore so I'm sorry
about that but if there was if you ask
the question early on you may want to
put it in there again because I I can't
see it
haha okay Savior at some point says his
face in the thumbnail looks like mine
when I'm coding so yeah I have a
confused thumbnail for the video I
thought it just it looked funny I
thought I'd put it in here
all right and I said I like your stream
Thanks
it's good to see you in the light yet I
haven't seen in the chat for a few days
so welcome back
okay Harsha says I found a site named
vulture the ultr
it's it's like digital ocean about
offers double resources for the same
amount of money oh that's cool I have to
check that out thank you all right Kat
des how long since you've learned coding
I've been I guess seriously doing
JavaScript for about three years now
in terms of just building websites it's
been about five years I first learned
about building websites and when I was
in high school so somewhere around the
year 2003 I think and then I did some
stuff in college just like some C++ just
really basic like I built a calculator
in C++ so nothing nothing too crazy and
then I didn't really work that much with
coding you know until till about five
years ago so if you want to know more I
have a video on my channel it's linked
in the description to this video and I
think the video is called my was a how I
became a front-end developer so you can
check that out if you want a little bit
more in-depth explanation
Albert asks what application I'm doing
basically we're doing a react app and
it's a it's it's a university bulletin
so it's gonna have a login system and
then once you log in you'll be able to
see a lot of different announcements
download attachments submit your own
announcements link what else yeah that's
pretty much it that's that's what it's
going to do cat DZ's three-hour meeting
sounds too long yeah well it was
actually two different meetings so the
first meeting was about an hour long and
then the second meeting which I thought
was only going to be a few minutes ended
up being almost two hours so yeah then
he'll be being long long time okay
and I'm the worst part of the whole
thing about all the meetings I'm super
hungry I thought I'd have time to eat
before I stream but I didn't so what my
stomach is killing me all right let's
see I'm gonna go back and do some more
coding let's um all right here's what
I'm gonna do and I'll give you my reason
as well I really like password this it
looks good but I'm not gonna use it for
this stream because I put in my tweet
about the stream and in the title for
this dream that I would be using
Passport so since I can't decide between
the two of them I'm just gonna use that
as my deciding factor I mean there's
also the benefit that I'm probably going
to switch up and implement some of the
other passport solutions as well so I
think that does give me a little bit
more freedom that I could potentially
implement multiple solutions from
passport if I wanted to at some point so
that's what I'm gonna go with that I
appreciate all the suggestions from
everyone and I I may use them like you
know I might end up using password lists
in a future project or who knows maybe
this project if this doesn't work out
but at this point I need to make a
decision so we can get something done
all right so let's go ahead and
let's see what we need to do so I assume
we're going to have to use ha ha to load
up passport first and it looks like
we're using Redis
okay I want to check this out and see if
they're bringing in
all right that's interesting
okay I may have just changed my mind yes
sorry sorry for being so indecisive but
now that I took a closer look at this
I'm not so sure that this will be the
easier way of the two because it seems
like and correct me if I'm wrong I've
never worked with with Redis but it does
not look like it's built into this
package or the passport package which
means I'll have to install that
separately and figure out how to use it
I'm not really I'm not really looking
forward to trying to do that on the
stream in the next 20 minutes where did
I put this
now
let's see
yeah okay maybe we will go with the
other module I was just checking the
live chat as well it looks like you are
noticing some some additional things
okay all right let's go with this one
it it includes some setup for things
that this one does not I would say this
assumes some knowledge of other things
that I don't have and this one is more
explicit about talking through the steps
so I think we have a better shot of
getting this one up and running faster
than the other one so apologies for the
misleading title I can always go back
and change that and I think I probably
will after this stream but I think we're
gonna end up going with this pasture
list so let's bring the terminal up
because we need to install some modules
okay
okay let's see let's go with yarn add
password this and we need also need to
add password Liz store and
this example saying email to use email
je s but I thought somewhere else that
said that you could use SendGrid
yeah I think on their their main hum
they just said that you could do you
send grade with it
hmm
I have accounts for both let's just do
let's do email js4 now because that'll
probably be it'll go along better with
the diffusion my princess it'll go along
better with their instructions right now
on the repo and I don't think we've set
up email j/s before on the stream so if
we went with sangria it would just be a
repeat of what we had done for the last
project so we'll go with email j/s just
to switch it up a bit okay
and we're gonna need to all right we'll
let that do its thing
and then now in our if we should do this
in our app Jess or if we should use
another file I'm not sure
yeah let's see how we have this maybe we
could and this uh
okay sorry for all the silence I'm
reading through the documentation and
and the documentation is very thorough
but to get this set up right now I think
would be better to take a look at their
fully functional example and copy that
just to get things going a little bit
more quickly so let's work this in here
we need to all right let me see what we
have alright we have body parts or
Express obviously
I won't really need some more stuff that
we it's not mentioned that's interesting
all right so basically the example that
they've given the example project has a
lot more going on than what they show in
the in the documentation so I was hoping
the example would would let us get
started quickly but now I'm not so sure
alright well let's just get started and
get as much done as we can I always
intended this to be more than one part I
figured it would be a two or three part
with with multiple streams so let's do
that so let's just require these things
that that we need so let's bring in
these let me change this to Const okay
so we brought in we've already let's see
yeah we did successfully pull in
password this password this store
an email je s and now we're gonna bring
in let's bring this and
change this to cost so if you want to
follow along with where I'm at I'm on
that password list github repository I'm
gonna put the link there in the live
chat and I want to step 3 well I just
finished step 3 well I'm just going to
get all the code in for now we'll fill
in our details later on I got a I'll
bring up on my other screen my email j/s
account and get the info that I need so
now we're on step 4
oops wrong screen okay here we go so I'm
gonna make a mess of this app dot J's
file right now we can always refactor
this and separate it out later on but
just to move a little bit faster for the
stream I'm not gonna worry about that
for right now
so basically we've for this step we are
initializing password lists with this
store all right and now we're gonna set
up our token delivery
so all these semicolons are killing me
all right
so assuming that we're gonna go with
email J s this is how it's recommended
to set this up which at least for now to
test it out we are going to use email J
us I might switch it up to send grid at
some point and then now we're on step
six we're gonna set up the middleware
okay I'm going through this pretty
quickly but if you want to learn more
about what's going on you can read all
the details that are there for each of
these steps
let's make sure we've setup
all right we need to I was just
double-checking to see if we've said
we've done this next step at some point
I'm one that steps seven
okay
let's see oh yeah hard should sing
always use node mailer I I'm using email
je s in this case because it's that's
what they're using for these docs so -
let me get it set up more quickly we can
always switch up to node mailer you know
after we get this going
okay
okay so we don't have this one right now
all right so place it we're on step 7
for the routers so let's just copy this
in so at this point I'm copy and pasting
a lot from the from the documentation
once we get it all in there we can give
it a you know give it a test then we can
go in there and change things if we need
to yeah
all right and it says in the
documentation that we want to make sure
using bawdy parser which we are I
believe we already have great we already
have that fixed list of users okay we're
skipping over that second part of step
seven because we don't in fact have a
fixed list of users so skip that over
okay now it has some code for a login
page I'm obviously not going to use that
for our login page because we're using
react so I'm not just going to copy in
that that HTML but we can do this in
react quickly let me check my time and
see what's down there not that much time
okay so we just need to make a very
basic basic form and let's see
so let's make that basic form we just
need to send it to the sent oaken path
and it looks like it just needs one
field I think we just need to just need
to send one one field which will be user
which in this case we're going to use
email
okay Harshit saying there's something up
with the code so it's not gonna work
okay he said I Jesse I don't think I
think you don't so much backend stuff
yeah yeah that's true I'm a front-end
developer that does back in when I have
to we don't have a back-end developer
here in in my department so I do what I
can
let's see so I'm trying to see where
okay so let's a dragon owner says but
you already have a transport that you
require on top
okay let me check that out so
okay yeah I'm not sure where we're
trying to figure out where the issue is
but I'm not sure
okay cat D says if you're using
WordPress isn't there an auth module
that you can use yes so that basically
there's going to be at least in my mind
there's gonna have to be two two parts
so since the wordpress is is like a
separate kind of issue like the first
thing is we want to have users
authenticated to be able to even access
anything within the react portion of it
and then our server is going to make
calls to the WordPress installation at
that point there needs to be something
basically something that make sure that
the WordPress data can only be accessed
by someone who's authorized so
essentially we don't need every user to
be able to directly access WordPress we
need but we do need every user to be
able to authenticate to access that
react part of it so maybe there's a
better way to set it up but I I don't
know that it would simplify things to
have the authentication kind of pass all
the way through to WordPress but that is
gonna have to be a part of it at some
point but as far as I think not
necessarily for the user yeah okay so
harsh it has it so I should saying you
you're required to authenticate
WordPress on the server only yeah so
basically the server on the react side
of things has to be able to make
requests to WordPress but not
necessarily the user right from the
client side
alright let's see I mean
[Music]
alright work says saying you mean it
won't work because of the res render he
can switch it to res send for testing no
an email JS file okay alright that's why
I'm not seeing it so it looks like car
should saying that the problem was in
the email Jas file okay yeah I'm not
okay cool oh it looks like harsh it's
making a PR right now so depending on
how long that takes we may be able to
just pull some stuff in so yeah
definitely you all can see how much like
difficulty I'm having because well
number one I'm not a back-end guy number
two this is really all harsh it's work I
haven't done anything with the server
dot or the app dot J's file for the
server so I'm not I'm not familiar with
how it's set up I certainly reviewed
everything before I pulled it in but I
mean you know how it is if you write it
yourself you're way more familiar with
it then if you're trying to add to
someone else's code which is the
position I'm in right now so thank you
for all the help
Harshit and everybody else that's that's
adding in a little okay eric says would
love to see a flow chart for your
authentication on this project that's a
great idea I should try to come up with
something for that because I have a
visual in my head of of the flow but it
might be a lot better if I could try to
put that in some sort of like visual
format for you all okay cool john b
spotted a typo let's um let me wait i'm
not going to change it right now i'm
gonna wait and see what's up with with
harsh its next pool request and then
i'll change it
ours was also asking did the male male
trap work i know i didn't have a chance
to to get it working before i so i just
had to come straight for the meetings
and started the stream so i didn't get a
chance to even test it out aside from
like the very first test i did that did
not work
see I can give it a shot I currently
have have the info let me make sure that
I have a
there we go I'm gonna I don't want to
show everybody my my dot m-files so I'm
moving it to my other screen and I'm
gonna open it up there just to make sure
that I have okay I do have the right
stuff in there actually I did I changed
my password and username so let me
update that
okay say that whoops let's make sure
I lost my whoa
oh I know why cuz I just messed it up
with all this obviously I just added a
bunch of stuff alright so I'm gonna
remove the stuff that I just did because
we have a pull request that is on its
way I need to get this working at least
see and I'm not that worried about
getting rid of this because
realistically I just copy and paste and
some stuff I didn't even make any
modifications so it'll take about three
minutes to get all that stuff back in
there again if I need to let's see that
was everything right yeah
let's just give it a little restart here
see if that fixes things yep
there we go
I'm gonna try to submit an announcements
whoa
that's it no that's probably not gonna
work because if it was going to work it
would have worked already
okay my timer did go up so let me do
another five minutes on my news okay let
me do another five minutes and let me go
back up to where I left off three or
four
okay our arvind says is the initial
setup done yeah the the setup for this
project it's done if if you go back and
watch some of the previous streams
you'll be able to check out the initial
setup so this is project force if you go
back to project for day one then that'll
be you know obviously the starting point
Sebastian says don't you need a database
to store data with Passport
yes I would assume
I think that's or that we were bringing
in that store
okay cool Gideon's watching so glad you
could join us
gideon says so late once hin don't worry
about it I was late to my own stream
zavier says just use the honor system
for us yeah
why don't I just make one password and
then I'll just email that pass for it to
everybody at the University and then
it'll be easy right it will just it
would just be really basic we'll just
have like user name user 1 and password
1 2 3 4 right obvious that change it
because I just told you that password so
that could work I actually believe it or
not I've seen systems like that where we
have something that's password protected
but literally the the password is shared
with everyone that works at the
University
okay so a few you're talking about using
JWT JSON web tokens so rang Shu says
JSON web tokens could work with just
email just validate the email for a
valid one as they says is there a reason
you don't want to use JSON web tokens
since the university has an email
address send the link to the email and
that should do the job I guess so
let me think don't you think
okay so let me sink through and you all
know I'm no expert on JSON web tokens
and how to set that up so you all if
you've used them help me out here
so the flow for the user then would be
they go to the site for the first time
they put in their email address we send
them an email then they would click the
link in that email then that would take
them that that would basically have the
token that would validate them at that
point we would then have to store we
would have to store that data for that
user and then if I want to keep them
login we'd have to store in local
storage or as a cookie or whatever some
data for that user in their own browser
and then when they try to come back we
check for that is that correct is that
how the flow should work and if so would
it be easier to just implement something
very simple like that on our own or
should we use one of these other
solutions arvind says i think you should
consider using the mapping of the email
with phone number if it ever be
necessary to send SMS considering this
we can proceed with password list i
guess can we start now please yeah yeah
with the SMS maybe we can have the
option for users to link it to their
phone number and then then I guess later
on if they need to log back in they
could choose to get a text instead of an
email that it might actually be
yeah that might actually be a nicer
option for people who are trying to use
their cell phone
okay
okay so it looks like in regard to the
JSON web tokens that may end up being
the simplest way to do it but we'll see
because harsh it's working on this pool
request so maybe I should see about that
first
okay let's see um so I guess I don't
know that I want to I don't want to put
pressure on Harsha to try to push
something out this quickly so I don't
know if we should wait for that probably
not
all right so you let me let me just go
ahead three I know the timer went up but
let me just finish up with all the
questions in the live chat here and then
we'll see if I finish up the questions
and we have something from a pull
request maybe we'll check it out
otherwise maybe we'll just have to
postpone and work on this so yeah so
sorry I didn't really get that much
accomplished but we did sift through a
lot of options and got a lot of
different ideas on what would be the
best way to do this so it's it's not it
was productive in that sense I did think
I'd have more time beforehand to get
some things ready so it just didn't
happen
oops
oh cool Blake says hey Jesse has
submitted a pull request on the free
code camp guides can you check it out to
see if it reads whoa and it's helpful
link okay cool off to check that out
not right now but maybe after the stream
I could check it out I just saw this
some hard
he says the the passport module so the
passport password list repo says it
looks kind of it looks hacky he's they
are using password lists internally
that's crazy
arvin says i think we have only harsh
in the house who knows password
this better than any we should listen to
him he may got yeah yeah it does seem
like harsh it has some experience with
using password list
okay cool dragon hunter unfortunately I
didn't catch all this earlier when I was
when I was actually doing some coding
the dragon owner said we already said
you already have note mailers set up you
can use that transport yeah that makes a
lot of sense we were already using it
for the other emails so in our email Jas
we're already bringing in node mailer so
could've used that like I said my
intention was to set everything up
exactly like it was in the documentation
for password list thinking that that
would allow us to at least have
something to test out as quickly as
possible
yeah buh buh Jen says boy that is a mess
of code James says high school in 2003
I'm about to show my age high school for
me was 94 computers we're not even a
consideration when I was going to school
and Brett says I'm Way older than James
it's always interesting I wonder what
age range we have in here I know we've
had I'm pretty sure we've had people who
are like less than 10 years old I can't
remember the exact age but we had some
people that are really young and I think
we've had people in their 60s on the
stream I think it's cool that we have
such a big age range and a range of
people from different locations around
the world that's that's awesome that we
all kind of work together you know on
these projects
Kaddi says TGIF thank goodness it's
Friday yeah
okay dragon hunter says why not an
authentication micro service which will
route East request a separate one
I don't I don't know enough about it to
know whether or not which one would be
better which one wouldn't be better ok
Umberto says when using Microsoft sequel
we make a service account for the server
machine to the database ok cool that's
that's kind of what I was thinking we'd
end up doing with the the WordPress is
that we would have a user account on
WordPress that would just basically just
be for our server to connect to
WordPress so I'm glad to hear that
that's that's how it's done
in other places as well because I mean
it seemed like it would work to me but I
wasn't sure that that would be you know
the proper way to do it
Ellen Umberto says and the application
controls what date of the login an
authenticated user sees yeah definitely
that's that's how I was thinking that
that it would work so so I'm not crazy
that's the legit way Haven
okay I'm getting towards the bottom of
the live chat it's gonna check see if
there's any more questions
okay we got so Arvin says okay I might
be a noob but don't worry about being a
noob I knew that many things as well but
says it might be a new but I just want
to know how to make multiple single page
applications and a website what I
basically mean is I should be able to do
single page application stuff in
multiple pages in the website what I'm
basically confused about is how do you
segregate multiple modules and
associated controllers and factories
okay
well I mean so you want to have a
website to where different routes in the
site
so I guess different sub directories
would be their own single page
applications that's what that's what I'm
getting from this if that's not what
you're saying then please let me know
I mean I guess as long as you have
something that's sitting in front of
your multiple single page applications
that's routing it to the different ones
I mean you could you could separate them
out like that so I'm not I guess it's
hard to it's hard for me to say without
kind of seeing more like what do you
what you're trying to do but whatever a
routing system that you have just have
the the various routes go to different
different applications some thinking
like usually
I mean potentially depending on what you
are using you could have so you can have
it set up so that all right so usually
how we set up our projects when we're
using react and note is we have nginx as
a reverse proxy potentially we could at
that level of the of nginx route traffic
to different node installations
different react apps based on the URL so
I mean you could do something like that
or at the level of node and Express you
could route things to different places
you know at that point I'm just not
exactly sure you know which you what
you're kind of looking for in terms of
how it's going to function I don't know
maybe I'm misunderstanding things if
anyone else has some some more
information and I'll check down here it
looks like alright it looks like you got
some more info here
okay so Arvind is saying I'm basically
using angular 1 running it and it uses
the controller and factory concept to
send receive data into my view let's say
I have five pages in my web app and all
our single page applications meaning
every page has say for routing so
collectively there are 20 routes as a
whole how do people manage to separate
modules for each page oh okay I I have
very very little experience with angular
so I don't know that I'm the best person
to to handle that question if we have
any angular people let's see okay so
dragon hunter seems to have some answers
here so saying if it's the same app that
routing is handled by the client app if
it's for multiple apps you can use Doku
which I've never used that
and since in each app could be in a
sub-domain
yeah definitely let's see okay
okay cool so thanks dragon owner for for
those answers yeah I'm definitely not
I'm not very knowledgeable about angular
stuff so I'll definitely admit when I
don't have enough in all this to answer
question properly
okay we have some some ages here so
seventeen twenty four thirty five thirty
twenty six twenty I'm 31 I actually be
32 next week what's today I'll be 32
that on the 29th of October so soon
okay harsh it says the PR is almost done
uh-huh Paco says you know the last
commit from angular was in 1886 they are
still debugging the code at Google I
don't want to get into any JavaScript
framework Wars here John B says I
believe you mean 1861 Paco that's when
the great angular Civil War started when
angular 2 changed the routing macho
this is in react sitting looking at at
angular analyst version with a big smile
eric says angularjs plus one still
learning more about react but it looks
really great MD says hi hey how's it
going thanks for joining us
oh cool Blake said I'll be 15 in a month
awesome actually Blake you might be the
youngest one in the stream so cool
awesome
okay let me I think
rat the bottom
all right I'm at the bottom of the live
chat I've gotten through everything so I
know our shits pretty close to finishing
up this pull request but I'm not sure
not streaming away around for it maybe
if I had eaten something today I might
wait around for it but huh I'm really
hungry so I'm right in the stream let's
see let's say there's still some
conversation going on here in the live
stream but no no questions so yeah so I
think there's definitely going to be a
part two to the authentication and maybe
down the road even a part three if we
end up switching to something else so
alright so my my energy level is is low
so I probably wouldn't be very
productive if I even try to do anything
at this point so dragon owners to start
a little Express project let's try
password list I can't I don't have I'm I
don't have the energy right now so yeah
alright so it's Friday right so I'll be
back Monday have a great day yeah so
sorry didn't didn't really accomplish
anything but we'll give it another go on
Monday probably harsh it'll have some
code for us to review and you know if
anyone else has any ideas for you know
what to do for authentication you know
I'm still open to that as well it's very
much still you know up for for
discussion so I'll be back next week
have a great weekend everybody and
thanks for watching